it's very dramatic and it's very
symbolic
it's worth telling you there have been
rocket attacks during eid before they've
been rockets attacks that have landed
in the presidential palace before but
i think coming at this very tense time
in afghanistan
it is a symbolic attack i can also tell
you that a senior taliban official
in the last few minutes has confirmed to
al-jazeera that the taliban
were responsible for this attack the
afghan president ashraf ghani
at the end of the prayers he gave a
speech
and he said with their missiles they
wanted us to leave but did you see
anyone leave the prayers i think trying
to show
that him and his key government
officials were very calm
at a difficult moment but clearly
again i think showing the vulnerability
of
the afghan government at this time there
were talks that took place
in doha ending on sunday and they
appear to have gone reasonably well but
the key thing that didn't come out of
those talks and which the international
community wanted which the un wanted
was a ceasefire to mark this religious
holiday the talks could not agree
that uh they simply said that they would
meet again soon to try and get a timely
and just solution and would try
to prevent uh civilian casualties but
clearly
uh for the taliban uh it's very clear
that they've not wanted at any stage
to have a ceasefire